paroles et à monsieur bernard gérard ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
à l'annoncé de la fermeture du leem du
laminoir de vallourec dans le nord
entraînant 460 suppressions de postes
les salariés se disent écoeurés
pourtant nous ne cessons de vous
interpeller sur la gravité de la
situation sur le front de l'emploi
malgré une conjoncture économique plus
que favorable en france la croissance
peine à redémarrer et le chômage
poursuit sa hausse inexorable
cela fait plusieurs semaines que plus
vous répondez à nos questions - nous
sommes rassurés est derrière nous plus
les français dans nos territoires
s'inquiètent
il est temps que vous vous posiez les
bonnes questions pourquoi avons-nous en
france le droit du travail le plus
protecteur
le taux de chômage le plus élevé qu'en
partout ailleurs le chômage régresse
parce que vos politiques ne traite pas
de croissance
vous n'êtes plus un stage de formation
monsieur le premier ministre
ce ne sont pas les autres qui sont
responsables c'est vous votre équipe est
votre politique
la situation se dégrade et vous
continuez à constater chaque mois la
hausse du nombre de chômeurs + 15 1800
catégorie a le mois dernier vous
continuez à constater l'effondrement du
nombre d'entrée en apprentissage - 10,7
pour cent depuis 2012 vous continuer à
alimenter la presse de déclarations
contradictoires sur le temps de travail
sur le code du travail sur des soi
disant plan emploi mais sans jamais
engagé de réformes structurelles grands
diseux petit faiseux disons-nous dans le
nord pour embaucher les entreprises ont
besoin de vitalité de sécurité regardez
l'allemagne
regardez l'italie l'espagne eux
apportent de la croissance à leurs
économies par des réformes d'ampleur et
courageuse
la réalité c'est que vous n'êtes plus
préoccupé à manipuler les statistiques
du chômage
en sortant cinq cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi des chiffres officiels pour un
coût exorbitant de 2 milliards d'euros
jusqu'à quand monsieur le premier
ministre allez vous attendre pour
engager des réformes structurelles et à
monsieur emmanuel macron ministre de
l'économie
de l'industrie et du numérique merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député il ya plusieurs
réalités qui sont derrière votre
question d'abord le sujet de la
stratégie économique et des politiques
en effet pour l'emploi qui sont
conduites il faudrait bien plus de deux
minutes pour répondre à tous les points
que vous avez soulevés et pour rappeler
aussi que l'histoire de notre politique
économique ne commence pas en 2012 que
cela nous plaise ou que cela nous
déplaisent
et il est vrai que certains pays ont
fait des réformes parfois il ya dix ans
et vous étiez aux affaires que ne les
avez vous fait alors la réalité la
réalité c'est que un tissu économique se
transforme lentement qu'avant qu'avons
nous fait le voc de l'est j'ai d'abord
baissé d'abord baisser le coût du
travail ce qui était une nécessité pour
la compétitivité coût ensuite il faut
investir montée en capacité pour pouvoir
innover et il faut en effet gagner en
flexibilité en adaptabilité
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
dans les lots à porter l'année dernière
c'est ce que myriam el khomri portera
dans les prochaines semaines à travers
son projet de loi
maintenant vous prenez pour soutenir
votre question le cas de vallourec
mais de quoi s'agit-il sur le cac
vallourec en l'espèce d'un problème de
cycles économiques
c'est la vérité c'est la crise du
secteur pétrolier et parapétrolier et le
dumping chinois sur la sidérurgie
ce n'est pas cela n'est pas un sujet
macroéconomiques de droit du travail
français
c'est un sujet sectorielle face à ça
quelles sont nos réponses
1 une action une action forte contre les
mesures anti dumping chinois ce que nous
allons continuer à mener avec matthias
fekl est encore dans les prochains jours
la seconde chose c'est une politique
industrielle à la hauteur du défi qui
est porté par vallourec lui permettent
de se réorganiser à travers les
restructurations un accompagnement de
tous les territoires
une recapitalisation du groupe dans
laquelle l'état prend sa part de
responsabilité et une stratégie
industrielle pour préparer l'avenir
mairie sallah est un monsieur